おい、はじめ！
はい
お前よぉ
どうすんだよこれ
はぁ、はい
そのとおりでございます
浮気に、ゴルフクラブ折って、叩かれて、一か月半も動画休んで何してたの？
ねえ？
ぼくですか？
そうだよ
えーまあとりあえずは、僕がいろいろ問題を起こしたので、反省してました
なるほどねぇ
まぁその反省と同時にですね
おう
反省してたんですけれども
も？
まぁ今まで動画を続けてきて
こう僕の中でいろんなものがたまっておりまして
ほぉ
正直言うと
燃え尽きてしまいました
それで？
燃え尽きちゃって
なんかこう動画を撮る気もなかったし
ほぉ
まあ僕がいろいろ問題を起こしたので
一回
落ち着いて
頭を冷やそうと思って
この一か月半は
ネットから、YouTubeから離れて生活していました
そゆことねー
反省しつつ休んでたのか
はい、そうです
で？
どうだったのよ
もう、すべて忘れてたわけです僕は
ほぉほぉほぉ
ネットからもYouTubeからTwitterからも離れて
なんにも囚われずに
なんて言えばいんでしょう(汗)
ま、泣くなって
泣いてないです
いや泣いて...
るじゃん
ううん？
まぁまぁ、いろんな事があったんですけれども
このお休み中は、今までお休みってものがなかったんで。1日も
確かにねー、 忙しかったもんねぇ？
まあ今回こうしっかり休めて
けっこうリフレッシュできたと思っています
で、
はい
よくお前戻ってきたな？ YouTube、やめないの？
やめないです！！！
どうして？
正直言っていいすか
言ってみろ
正直...
何を撮っていいかわかりません
そうなのか...なるほどなぁ
何を撮っていいかわかんないんですけど
動画を撮りたくて戻ってきました！
ふ〜〜ん
で？
まぁ今回の件でですね
はい
大勢の人を傷つけ、大勢の人を悲しませ、大勢の人を失望させたと思っております
ほぉ
それで？
僕は、こんな僕でも待っててくれた皆さん
僕の動画を楽しみにしてkra$bu"(#'$%･･･
ばかやろぉぉぉぉぉぉ！！！！！
はいぃぃ！！！
今お前噛んだだろ
はい
休みすぎなんじゃないの?
結構緊張してます...
よかろう許す
ありがとうございます
こんな僕でもまだ動画を待ってくれている人がいるので
おう
それでも待ってくださる皆さんのために
僕は
動画を出したいと思いました
お前Twitter見てた?
Twitter見ていませんでした。アプリ消してました
はぁ？
ばかやろうかお前は
ボッコボッコにたたかれてたけどw
ウウ(泣)
毎日たくさん応援のメッセージ来てたんだぞ...
そうだったんですね
（こっそり見てたけど・・）
お前さー、Twitter復活したものの
全然つぶやかなかったじゃん
はい
なんで？
まぁいろいろわけがあったんですよ
わけ？ わけとは何だ？ 述べてみよ
いろいろ言われるわけじゃないですか
はい 確かに それは...仕方ないことだからな
仕方ないんですけども、僕そういうコメントに一切反応しないんですよ
おう
それが僕だったら...いいんですよ
おぉおぉおぉ
僕にいろいろ批判されるのは仕方ないことなんで、それはいんですけども
うん
なんか、もう逆に、反応しないって気づいちゃってて皆
あーー
俺も気づいてた
気づいてましたか
もちろん
僕がスルーしてると何が起きるかといいますと
僕はもうなに言っても反応しないじゃないですか
ほぉ
となると、僕の視聴者さんにこう批判とか、攻撃とかし始めるんですよ
なるほどなぁ...
で、結局こう、僕の視聴者さんが批判されて
で、その視聴者さんたちも負けじとこう、言い返しちゃって、こう戦いみたいなの起きてて
おぉ
もうそうなっちゃうともう、こうじゃないっすかこう。わかります?
わか...
おお そうだな
もうこうなっちゃってて
批判に批判の繰り返しでもう
終わんないんすよ
おぉ
こうなるともう、止められないんで、僕が何言ってもヒートアップするだけなんで
おう
止められなかったんで、僕に何ができるかと思ったときに
まぁその場から消えるのが正しいなと思って、僕はネットから姿を消しておりました
そういうことだったんだなぁ
そうなんです
お前が何言っても、事態がヒートアップするだけだしなぁ
だから僕一つ言いたいことがありまして
なんだ?
あの...
本当に今応援してくれる人たちを僕、傷つけたくないんですよ
うん
でもたぶんこれからもそういった批判的なことは
あり続けると思うし
おぉ
これからも言い続ける人はいると思うから
うん
あの、僕の視聴者さんの皆さんはできればこう、批判を批判しないでほしいです
ほぉ
無視してほしい
無視？
結局そういう人たちってこう、反応を楽しんでるわけなんで
反応をねぇ
みんなが傷つく必要はないんで
できればスルーしてほしいなって思っています
そういう理由もあったんだねぇ...
実はそうなんです
ほほぉ
そして、この休止中に僕、考えてたことが一つだけあります
考えてたこと？
はい
なんだい
今後のことっす
今後のこと？
はい
ほほぉ、気になるねぇ
あの正直言いまして
割と一人でやっていく自信がありません
一人でやっていく自信がない？
はい
何故？
うまく言えないんですけど
ほんとはもっとこう元気に復活したかったんですよ
ほぉ
復活しました！ これからも頑張ります！
みたいな感じで出ようと思ったんですけど
うん
正直そういうテンションでもないんで今
まぁまぁまぁまぁまぁ
結構今回の件で影響力がでかすぎるっていう事が分かったんですよ
今？ 今更か？
今更です
ばかやろぉぉ！！！
さぁせぇぇぇん！！！
考えが甘いわ～～～～～！！！！
すいませんしたぁぁぁ！！！！！
まぁそれに気づけたなら、いんじゃない？
なんでこう、軽い気持ちで今までやってて、YouTubeって遊びだと思ってたんですよ
うーん
今回の件で色々僕もいろいろ反省したことがあったので
僕は馬鹿なので
ばかやろぉぉぉ！！！
僕は馬鹿なので！
おぉ
いろいろ考えなきゃいけないなと思って、今後のこといろいろ考えておりました
なるほどね？ いろいろ考えてたわけだね
ありがとうございます
いろいろ言われると思うけどさぁ
はい
応援してくれる人のためにせいぜい頑張れや
頑張ります！
じゃぁ...最後に一言
えー、待ってくださった皆様
大変お待たせいたしました
そして、待ってくれてありがとうございました
えー、間違いなく賛否両論あると思いますが
僕は自分のしたいことをします
そして、応援してくださる皆様に、感謝して
皆さんを大切にして
これからも動画を頑張っていきたいと思っております
約１か月半、お休みをいただいて
落ち着いて自分自身と向き合って
いろんなことを考えて今後二度と
同じような過ちを繰り返さないように
YouTubeがんばっていきたいと思いますので
これからも、はじめしゃちょーを
よろしくお願いいたします
うぅ╰(◉ᾥ◉)╯
ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑
えー本日のニュースです
なんと約１か月の間活動を休止していた
あの超人気youtuberはじめしゃちょーが復活しました
同じ事務所のＨＩＫＡＫＩＮ氏も
「comeback」と言ってたほどで
多少叩かれている中でも
ファンからの歓声をたくさん浴びております
※次回ゴルフクラブをもう一度正しく扱います
ではまた次回の動画をお楽しみに！